[Music]
getting our first look at Bristol Palin
on Teen Mom og we saw the trailer last
night during the VMAs but here's the big
question what does her mom think I
wasn't Imam my life is not perfect at
all amen
MTV offered up this first look at
Bristol's upcoming season during last
night's VMAs the now 27 year old who
found out she was pregnant with her
first child at age 17 has her mom's full
support the former governor of Alaska
posted this pic of her daughter with the
caption Wow
the opportunity she has to help others
along life's challenging journey his
exciting and outstanding I am so proud
of her I want to do what's best for my
kids Bristol will reportedly earn
$250,000 for her first season on the
show with is she ready to be back in the
spotlight
back in 2010 she tangled her way through
Dancing with the Stars and told us then
and she could handle any criticism
thrown her way yeah I'm ready for it and
in the tabloids a law for negative
things and I have tough skin
I'm ready Fran Bristol cher son trip
with former boyfriend Levi Johnston in
2015 she announced her second pregnancy
expecting daughter Saylor with then
boyfriend Dakota Meyer who she later
married and had another child with but
it was left in an ideal situation for
the outspoken advocate for abstinence
and teen pregnancy prevention what if I
didn't have all these opportunities
believe me
it wouldn't be pretty if I could just
prevent one person from getting pregnant
as a teen I all this would be worth it
but joining the cast of this series
should come as no surprise
turns out the noun divorce brisk who's
been a fan of the show for a long time
team on bridezillas mom and right
syllables knew your guilty pleasures Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]